il y a un signal un autre signal qui
vous a été envoyé euh par le Président
de la République euh parmi vos demandes
il y a celle d'avoir un référendum sur
l'immigration parmi les demandes des
républicains dimanche soir il a écrit
une lettre au chef de parti en disant
qu'il souhaitait élargir le champ du
référendum euh aux questions migratoires
vous allez saisir cette main tendue vous
le vivez comme une main tendue je vais
quand même commencer par dire que la
d'abord c'est un sujet constitutionnel
c'est pas ce texte qui va le résoudre
euh c'est dans le projet de loi la
proposition de loi le projet de loi la
proposition de loi conselle pardon que
nous avons déposé au mois de mai dernier
ça fait l'objet de discussion du groupe
de travail qui se réunit autour du
président Larcher d'ailleurs demain
matin pour vous donner un scoop si vous
voulez demain matin à 7h nous y serons
ça fera partie de nos débats donc
qu'est-ce que je veux dire par là c'est
que la modification de l'article 11 qui
permettrait de pouvoir ouvrir la phase
du référendum sur des sujets de cette
nature nous paraît tout à fait utile
elle est absolument c'est nécessaire ça
permet sur des sujet fondamentaux
d'avoir une une consultation en direct
de la population est-ce que le Président
de la République fait un pas vers nous
plutôt que nous vers lui la réalité
c'est que le Président de la République
fait un pas vers nous puisque c'était
notre proposition c'est notre
proposition que nous en débattons demain
je vous l'ai dit dans notre groupe de
travail autour du président Larcher et
donc c'est plutôt une nouvelle
intéressante qui nous arrive reste en
définir maintenant les conditions ce qui
n'est pas le plus simple mais mais vous
avez vous l'accueillez bien parce qu'ier
BR il a dit on n pas les perdre de en
parl de de cette ouice que c'est un peu
la façon de vous dire que c'est une
volonté qui était la nôtre et que c'est
nous qui avons l'idée vous savez en
matière politique il y a un principe
c'est comme en droit en fait de meuble
possession vos titres c'est-à-dire que
celui qui a l'idée et ben il l'a pour
toujours alors le jeu consiste souvent à
aller plus vite que les autres la
réalité c'est que nous avons annoncé
cette volonté depuis longtemps c'est
quand même notre idée notre projet et si
le président de la République il vient
c'est
parfait